chances are no matter which game you
play you don't just want to be good
while you're playing it
you want to look good from mobas to
sports games fighting games battle
royale's arena Brawlers Auto chess
clones and of course tax Shooters
cosmetic focused micro transactions are
everywhere and whether you're using an
in-game currency or real money many
so-called skins have a set value some of
the prices are determined by the
publisher or the developer of the game
While others change based on how the
community rates them but nowadays
certain games have outgrown their humble
old stores and evolved into having a
full-blown skin economy in the real
world and it's fair to say that no games
skin economy comes even close
to CS Scopes
no no no no no
oh my God it's got these four stickers
on it and these stickers are currently
worth 40 000 each so that's about 160
000 of skins on a single gun three two
one take Nola
over the past couple of years the Cs go
skin Market has gone absolutely nuclear
some Cosmetics go for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and by purchasing
certain skins you might actually be
making a Real Life Investment but how
the hell did we get here like how is it
possible that some of these digital
pixels are valued at such ludicrous
amounts of money let's find out together
foreign
so today is the day that I have been
waiting for for a very very long time
they finally let me make a cracked
just about CS go skills I'm sure some of
you already know that I am something of
a skin fiend but for those of you who
don't or don't know very much about CS
go Skins to begin with let me Enlighten
you back in August of 2013 valve
released what was arguably CS goes most
iconic and important patch ever the arms
deal updates added over a hundred weapon
skins into the game for players to equip
and collect you could get cases from
playing matches and then purchase a key
to open them and then you just sit there
and pray that you got something
serviceable but most importantly valve
decided that they wanted these cases and
skins to be available for purchase on
the steam Marketplace and and this is
crucial tradable between individual
accounts now this was obviously designed
so that players could just pick a
particular skin and either buy it or
trade for it but since there wasn't
really anyone monitoring these
interpersonal transactions this opened
the door for a sea of scammers thank you
Cosmo for the
the little uh
little thing
wait
some players fell victim to the
countless steam impersonators trading
skins away to scammers before realizing
their mistake others were suckered in by
skin gambling sites whose predatory
infrastructures amassed their fair share
of victims these early days housed some
of the darkest moments in the history of
Cs go not to mention one of the dumbest
most memed upon apology videos ever made
I have no idea how I'm going to record
this video dude
foreign
made an apology video for it and it is
Turbo shitty so I wanted to just kind of
talk about it so the video starts with T
Martin talking to a special guest Air
Bud and they're running a promotional
for air Bud's new movie Air Bud gambles
on CS go Skins as the years went on skin
gambling continued to be a very hot
topic within the general Gaming
Community so more and more sites where
you could purchase skins with real money
and eliminate the need to gamble began
to pop up but how exactly were you
supposed to know how much a skin was
actually worth players could technically
list these skins for however much they
wanted and some sites used site-specific
currency so how could you avoid getting
ripped off well there are a number of
reasons why certain skins cost
inordinately more than others most of
which have to do with looks and Rarity
and when those two things come together
in that perfect combination
that's when you stumble upon the big
bucks
non-stop Grays so let's go you know I
opened a night before in these yeah
hopeless yeah yeah
there are eight different skin grades
within CS go ranging from consumer grade
all the way to covert special rare and
contradict some feature various gun
skins While others are reserved for
higher ticket items like gloves and
knives next we have what is arguably the
most important factor for determining a
Skins value and that is where there are
five different wear ratings in the game
battle scarred well-worn field tested
minimal wear and Factory new battle
scarred means that the skin is super
beat up and Factory new means that it's
in pristine or near pristine condition
but when a skin is unboxed from a crate
it is also assigned a number ranging
anywhere from 0.00 to 1.00 and this my
friends is where you get the float float
values play a massive role in
determining the price of a skin and
luckily for you guys and for me because
I'm kind of out of breath I brought
along my boy Colton to help explain them
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about well I may not be
glad that you've dragged me out here for
yet another Counter-Strike video
at least you let me talk about a
computer science term for a change so I
guess I'll let it slide float short for
floating Point refers to a system for
representing decimal numbers to some
fixed Precision in binary what does that
have to do with weapon skins well if you
inspect any skin in CS go then hover
over the information icon at the bottom
of your screen you'll see four things
finish style finish catalog pattern
template and wear rating and that last
one is the one we actually want to focus
on the decimal number that makes up the
wear rating is what these CS go skin
fiends call the float value which by
default actually ranges from 0.06 to 0.8
and can change from skin to skin so best
to do your research on the individual
skin you're eyeing up not often I get
the correct Dimitri on something
Counter-Strike related there is some
really cool math that goes into how the
game actually generates that number if
you're a fellow math or CS nerd I mean
computer science not Counter-Strike then
I recommend checking out this post from
cscoflow.com that goes into way more
detail than I can in this video to put
it simply the higher the wear rating the
higher the opacity value on the scratch
and wear texture on top of the skin
meaning a more beat up looking AK or an
OP whose colors aren't quite as crisp
and bright Factory new flow values hover
between effectively zero and 0.07 with
the lowest possible float currently
being the
0.00089966 M249 Gator mesh minimal wear
is between 0.07 and 0.15 field tested up
to 0.37 well worn up to 0.44 and lastly
battle scarred from 0.44 to essentially
one now obviously Factory new is the
gold standard almost everyone wants
their skins to look as nice as possible
but you can often find low float minimal
wear skins that look pretty damn close
to factory new while valve has
intentionally left gaps in the float
values at the edges of each tier the
lowest float number within each one will
often look better than what the name
suggests so buying low float skins with
slightly worse wear can help you find
some sweet deals and speaking of sweet
deals for this episode of crack we've
teamed up with Predator gaming to bring
you my own personal holiday gift guide
[Music]
wait a minute a segment within a segment
and now we're just somewhere else inside
my house
I guess we have to keep the lights on
somehow anyway here's a look at my
holiday gift guide I recently got an
internet upgrade and now I need an
ethernet switch that can handle more
than gigabit speeds preferably something
like the 10 gigabit m4300 from Netgear
to manage all my ndi needs one of my
favorite ways to disconnect from the
internet though is with my guitars and
I've been hunting for regretch
Streamliner for a while now the P90
pickups in these things are just perfect
and of course with so many people
traveling for the holidays even Gamers
and video editors a powerful laptop is
at the top of a lot of lists and
Predator gaming is giving the people
what they want with the Predator Triton
300SE a slim and Sleek laptop with the
power of a 12th gen Intel Core i7
processor Custom Engineered Cooling and
Nvidia GeForce RTX 3060 series Graphics
more than enough the game or even edit
On The Go and all of this Computing
horsepower can be found at bestbuy.com
and now we Wormhole our way out of two
segments back to Dimitri
foreign
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about all right so
flow to values can play an extremely
crucial role in determining the value of
a skin but there is an even added layer
of complexity and that is pattern
templates sometimes referred to as a
skin seed a pattern template can range
between one and one thousand now this
can drastically change the look and
color of a skin and it's for this reason
that certain case hardened skins like
blue gems are some of the most expensive
skins on the market I had a guy reach
out to me who didn't have the owner
added because that guy's kind of like
really private he's called Newbridge and
he's held it for four years or five
years or something he told me to reach
out to him with an offer of
1.2 million in Bitcoin and I'm not
talking about USD I'm talking about
Euros which converts to 1.5 million USD
D now we have seen rifle skins sell for
hundreds of thousands of dollars before
like this super sick scar patterned AK
with four Titan Hollows and this m4a4
howl with four I buy Power Hollows
certain crafts with Caddo 14 Titan
Hollows or I buy Power Hollows are
valued at insanely high prices because
the major was eight years ago and you
can't unbox them anymore and well these
teams no longer exist
two
oh my God
it's common for collectors who own high
tears such as these to lend them out to
CS GoPros so they can Flex them during
their official matches there's even a
Discord server that was established in
service of facilitating this very
exchange the Chinese skin Market
exploded when CS go was released there
in 2017 and since then buff 163 has
become the best way to verify a Skin's
real price think of it as The Unofficial
Blue Book of Cs go Cosmetics whatever
it's listed for on Buff that's how much
a skin is worth that said there are tons
of skin collectors out there who are on
the hunt for items that have never been
seen before
why well because some of the most
expensive CS go Skins imaginable
haven't even been unboxed yet China is
actively trying to hunt it if if we get
a number one scar pattern step track
flight Channel it would be around about
a million dollars and as much as I've
talked about everyone wanting Factory
new blue gems and souvenir Dragon Lords
and
there is a wave
actors out there hell-bent on
ignoring the skin status quo and
pursuing the absolute ugliest most
scratched up skins they can get their
hands on thus driving up in the prices
of high float items as a result I
suppose there is a certain Beauty in
Decay one of them is this USPS kill
confirmed the worst condition covert
skin in the world this Skin's also got
six knives in its float too so whoever
unboxed it got insanely lucky to get a
skin this bad or insanely unlucky I
guess it depends on how you look at it
so what have we all learned today well
whether ugly beautiful or just
prohibitively expensive CS Go's skin
economy is in a league of its own it's
become an entire business and source of
content for many people around the world
things have gotten so crazy that you
could quite literally make a fortune
just by unboxing the right Skin So if
anyone's ever harassing you over how
much you opted to spend on Virtual
pixels in Counter-Strike make sure you
let them know how much it was when you
bought it versus how much it's worth
CS go Skins are like fingerprints
everyone is unique some of us just want
skins that look cool While others want
to collect the rarest of the rare so
that they can Flex on Scrubs and you
know let everyone know that they have
something special the skin Market might
seem kind of intimidating at first and
in a sense it is but once you take the
time to learn about it and understand it
and appreciate it you will soon
understand that
there's nothing quite like it